and I love Trump I mean I think he's a
great guy I mean when I say that I
actually mean that on a more like
personal I think he's a great guy really
you know Clay and I spent a lot of time
with him I've actually known him and the
family since I was a little kid in New
York too not well but you know I met him
different events and things he went to
prom with Ivanka um
Junior Prom it was like she was a friend
I can't believe he just blew me off you
know I would
figure him out so we gotta give a [__]
about afghanistanians like CIA yeah
exactly what you've been like he went to
prom with the [__] looking at you in a
whole different way here I thought you
were this big-headed dude that just you
know talks politics now I know you got
some games yeah it was uh it was no
there's no photo of it online it was
Junior it was Junior Prom
Junior Prom Junior you went with Ivanka
let's relax you're doing your thing so
um yeah I mean Jared's a very powerful
man
by the way have you guys this is totally
have you guys gone to your uh your wives
or girlfriends like high school reunions
or college reunions have you guys been
to any of those events no oh well so but
this is an experience see who they dated
you're saying yes I mean I did have the
the LA Times reached out to me I saw the
DM somewhere on Facebook and they were
just like we've seen the photos of you
at Ivanka at the Regis prom like would
you like to comment I didn't even
respond I was like what am I gonna
comment like we were the 15 year old
kids like we're there's like priests
everywhere I went to a Jesuit school I
don't even understand what we're talking
about yes but not on the road it was
funny though because she she I mean she
was she's a a total sweetheart and a
really really nice I always been a
really nice person
um I didn't realize how much at the time
it was it actually was the other girls
who were there who all because she was
really big in the like uh 16 magazine or
you know whatever you know team those
kind of like fashion magazines for
younger people back in the day man so
she was taking photos with them for like
I was just like there by myself talking
to guys like yeah you know she's my
friend she came you know she was not my
girlfriend uh I don't want to like
overplay this but um anyway she's she's
a cool lady so I've known the trumps for
a long time so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]